now then Palestinian worshipers have
been forcibly dispersed from the Alexa
Moss compound Israeli forces say it's in
response to Palestinians setting up
barricades to prevent Jewish groups from
entering Israeli police have increased
their presence in the Holy site in
occupied East Jerusalem at least two
people have been arrested Let's cross
straight away to Natasha name who's in
occupied his Jerusalem so Natasha what's
the latest what's happening right now
a short time ago someone got on the
loudspeaker inside the el-oxa compound
and said the Israeli police are quote
invading and putting out a call for
people to come and quote defend Al-Aqsa
right now we have about 17 people have
been injured five of them have been
taken to the hospital their wounds
include rubber bullet wounds and
beatings we know that at least two
people have been arrested according to
Israeli police this began early this
morning around the time of the Dawn
prayers when Israeli police said that
they had to go inside the el-oxa
compound because a barricade was formed
at the gate that non-muslims use to
access Al-Aqsa compound Israeli police
or excuse me the Israelis have a key and
restrict access in any event the Israeli
police said they went in dispersed and
since then several waves of Jewish
groups have been allowed to access the
el-oxa compound beginning at about 7 30
local it is a designated visiting hour
period for non-muslims we have about
15-20 minutes left of that designated
visiting period during Ramadan for
non-muslims the visiting hours are
greatly reduced but as you can imagine
the tension because the memory of what
happened on Friday when more than 400
people were arrested more than 150
people injured is still fresh in the
minds of many so who is inside
Al-Aqsa today these are a variety of
Jewish groups that include Jewish
settlers Ultra nationalists and Zionist
groups they believe that they have the
right to pray inside the el-oxa compound
right now all they're allowed to do is
wander around the grounds they are not
allowed to pray and they are not allowed
to perform any kind of ritual in a
recent recent years the numbers of these
groups have increased they've become
more vocal about their desire to pray
inside the Al-Aqsa compound that is
where a site called The Temple Mount
also sits it is very holy to Jews and
this morning we have seen increased
numbers from a typical Sunday that is
because it's the Passover holiday it's
converging with Ramadan so there is
heightened demand for access to the
compound we've seen children boys girls
women and men inside the compound but
again in about the next 15 minutes or so
their access will end we did see video
of buses carrying these Jewish groups
severely vandalized outside of the gate
to the old city police have arrested two
people so far
and so Natasha the um there's there's
all sorts of pressure points aren't
there around this time and today Sunday
is another one why is that
well it's uh still part of the Passover
holiday but for all of our viewers this
is a the first time in more than 30
years that the uh convergence of Easter
Passover and Ramadan uh have come
together so as I said there's heightened
demand for access to the compound but
people might just to recap wonder why
there's such a state of agitation there
was the violence on Friday that I
alluded to but we need to back up to
March beginning on March 22nd there were
a series of four attacks in Israel that
killed 14 Israelis in response the
Israeli Security Forces launched an
ongoing operation in the West Bank about
two dozen Palestinians have been killed
dozens arrested there have been uh
criticism of a heavy-handed approach and
Collective punishment on the part of the
Israelis and add to that in the days
leading up to Passover uh on Friday
there was a fringe group that had been
offering a cash prize for anyone who
would get inside the el-oxa compound and
sacrifice a goat there had been calls
before to do such a thing the Israeli
government has never allowed that to
happen six people were arrested but this
campaign went viral on social media
calls were put out for Palestinians to
come to El AXA and quote defend it and
Thursday night hundreds of people
actually spent the night in Al-Aqsa
which might explain again the volatility
that was there when the clashes began on
Friday morning
thanks very much for that update Natasha
can name that